le 21e siècle sera-t-il féminin c'est le
thème de notre débattent pour échec et
mat
pour répondre à cette question christine
clerc qui publie la lettre à un petit
garçon chez plon et eric zemmour pour le
premier sexe alors je vais vous
présenter
christine clerc vous êtes origines de
lyon vous avez fait des études de droit
sciences po et l'école du louvre
d'accord voilà donc vous êtes romancière
journaliste et vous collaborez à
marianne à rtl et vous m'avez demandé de
préciser au télégramme de brest
alors on se souvient et quelque chose de
plus grave de l'attentât dont vous avez
été victime en 2003 en corse à la suite
d'un article où vous dénonciez jédir les
violences qui était exercée contre les
continentaux en corse et qui vous a valu
quelques déboires
on va dire ça comme ça de façon assez
mystique je vais vous présenter
eric zemmour alors eric zemmour vous
êtes né en 58 à montreuil et oui alors
dans votre biographie comme une tâche
vous qui avez toujours été premier de la
classe diplômé de sciences po vous allez
manquer l'ena je crois que ça vous a
traumatisé à vie et âcre et admissibles
et j'ai manqué l'oral alors n imaginez
pas que ça m'a marqué à pavie mais ça
n'aura qu'un temps
enfin imaginer qu'eric zemmour at l'oral
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on a pas bien
croire alors donc vous avez tendu lié
dans la publicité vous avez fait du
journalisme et vous êtes romancier
essayiste et puis vous avez des des
ouvrages qui ont des titres que je
trouve intéressant balladur
immobile à grands pas pas mal et l'homme
qui ne savait pas portrait de jacques
chirac alors vos deux ouvrages
christine clerc lettres un petit garçon
vous êtes une grand-mère qui allait dire
rédiger un espèce de petit traité à
l'égard de votre petit garçon qui a dix
ans pour faire en sorte que ce garçon
échappe à espèce de prédominance de la
violence et du mépris des femmes qui
semble être celui qu'on constate
actuellement est ce que c'est bien ça la
procution est heureux voilà un petit
traité de savoir vivre pour un garçon
aujourd'hui eric zemmour c'est un peu
plus radicale ce que vous avez fait vous
c'est à dire un pamphlet on
c'est bien le convoi l'arrêt c'est un
genre c'est un jour c'est un agent
littéraire c'est pas genre et et rami
n'a pas du tout pas du tout dans le club
à vous
dressez je puis dire contre la
féminisation de notre société et vous
c'est peut-être un petit traité plutôt
aux garçons un petit traité de virilité
pour les garçons dans un monde civilisé
failli appeler exactement sa famille et
tracer un des petits c'était à des
titres possibles traité de savoir vivre
j'explique le principe vous bien sûr
vous débattez et que vous interrompez
vous prenez la parole en appuyant sur ce
petit bouton et vous interrompez sur le
même beaucoup voulu intervenir un chien
ça se vit alors moi j'aurais donné un
autre titre j'aurais appelé ça le
complexe de cro magnon
parce que quand on oublie on a
l'impression qu'on font le rêve c'est un
homme qui était voulu ça vous y tenait
beaucoup
velud est un gros gourdin
vêtus de peaux de bêtes qu'ils savaient
pas trop qui pourrit sentir mauvais quel
est dehors et puis alors surtout il se
tapait toutes les filles qui pouvaient
c'était formidable personne lui faisait
la morale
les filles ne demandez pas qu'on les
aime et cetera ça c'était fort un gars
étaient là les droits c'est une vision
complètement d'après mans et rené de ce
que j'ai écrit qu'est ce que j'ai voulu
écrire j'ai voulu d'abord montré à quel
point nous étions dans une société
féminine à la fois pour la parure parler
du volume et le velu n'est pas
anecdotique
le leu leu dans l'histoire dans
l'histoire de l'occident j'ai trouvé ça
dans des historiens très sérieux la
séparation entre le dru et le lys est un
des critères de distinction entre
l'homme et la femme et au delà de ça
j'ai voulu montrer une société qui
révèrent les valeurs féminines par
exemple le lit d'un terreau plan parce
qu'on voulait on a l'impression que ça
vous est tombé dessus tout tacot avant
c'était merveilleux y avait un an
tous les hommes régnait puis tout à coup
les femmes changent tout c'est une
horreur
mais vous savez sous louis xiv louis xiv
c'était quand même pas une lavette il
avait mis des dentelles des talons
rouges des rues van bon bien avancé jean
pagé des prêts à vous laisser parler ma
peau dure et d'autoriser mourir ce jeu
évidemment ça n'a rien à voir évidemment
il y a deux choses aujourd'hui il y a
d'une part les parures donc ça
évidemment ça existait avant au 16ème au
dix septième etc
mais il ya aussi les valeurs le 14 il a
des valeurs guerrières
il a des valeurs d'ordre il a des
valeurs de force de loi
aujourd'hui nous avons des valeurs tout
inverser le culte de la paix de la
tolérance de du consensus du dialogue
c'est le mépris de la loi
je pense que le capitalisme joue la
féminisation de la société parce que je
pense que maintenant le capitalisme ne
veut plus que des consommateurs et que
dans la structure traditionnelle
l'homme était un producteur la famille
des capitalistes veulent plus que des
consommateurs s'appuient sur des
publicitaires qui font quoi des femmes
des enfants des [ __ ] mais nécessaire
pour rêver parce que nous on voulait
peut-être surtout pas se laisse pas un
enfant de l'amour avec le désir mais
elle même nous embêtent les femmes qui
confondent l'amour avec le désir de
conrad ne ment pas du tout elles ne
peuvent pas s'en empêcher
c'est pas grave je trouve ça très bien
ce que je pense que je que ce jeu
condamné ce que ce que je que je dis
qu'il c'est grave c'est que aujourd'hui
la société veut imposer aux hommes le
même comportement
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans les
années 70 les féministes et vous savez
très bien christine on dit maintenant
c'est fini on va vivre comme les hommes
on va on va on va aimer comme les hommes
on va baiser comme les hommes
on va voir autant d'âmes ans qu'on veut
et on pourra séparer l'amour du désir
comme les ans on va des donjons
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
laissez moi finir je vous en prie deux
minutes qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
trente ans plus tard c'est exactement
l'inversé comme si les femmes avaient
renoncé à ce projet prométhéen et
qu'elle disait maintenant eh bien
maintenant c'est aux hommes de faire
comme nous est d'avoir un le même
comportement
justement un moment peut-être elles se
sont plantés à force de vouloir de
l'égalité et c est de la porter sur tout
maintenant on se retrouve tout seul avec
leurs enfants et les hommes ne les aide
pas du tout à les élever dans notre que
plus mais tout mettre sur le dos des
femmes mais aussi d'hommes ce continent
non c'est pas une conséquence du
féminisme c'est une conséquence du fait
qu'il ya plus de travail de force qu'il
n'y a pas de guerre que donc l'homme
pour s'affirmer bombal une partie de
tennis c'est un peu juste alors alors il
s'affirme comme en cent la brutalité
gratuite elle a prononcé une phrase il
n'y a que les hommes faibles qui refuse
la tendresse ce qu'ils ont pensé il n'y
a que les hommes facture à plus de
tendresse qui conduisent comme des
brutes et de choses de choses évidemment
que il faut pas refuser la tendresse
évidemment que la tendresse c'est
formidable évidemment que j'adore les
gestes temps voilé mais ce que je dis
j'essaye d'expliquer pourquoi nous avons
aujourd'hui une explosion de
l'impuissance une explosion du divorce
de masse parce que vous en savez qu'ils
n'étaient pas un puits sans armée parce
qu'il n'y avait pas de statisticiens
savez on n'y avait pas des six l'homme
qui avait geignant sur rue
j'essaie simplement d'expliquer la
problématique masculine du désir et de
l'amour je suis longuement stendhal qui
est passionnant là dessus qui dit aux
premiers grains de passion il y à un
premier grain de fiasco j'essaie donc
d'expliquer pourquoi les hommes ont
beaucoup de mal avec cet ordre qui leur
est donnée dans la société 2d mais pour
désirer et pourquoi les jeunes gens ça
vient peut-être de certains
publicitaires sa mère mais ça vient pas
départ on met dans la tête des jeunes
garçons un modèle qui est rocco alors
évidemment il faut il le mans s'est reco
rocco siffredi correctement alors ça
c'est quel point qui est paraît il y en
a certains qui se font même terreau et
grandes écoles c'est seulement parce
qu'ils croient qu'ils ont non pas une
assez longue mais ça sert à rien alors
c'est alors vous vous agissez un peu
dans ce sens sont arrivés à bon alors
pourquoi non ce que de virer police est
pour moi la virilité c'est de savoir se
dominer justement savoir ya une
différence entre la lave la bête qui ne
s'est pas de mine et ses pulsions et la
virilité qui est celui qui sait se
dominer qui est l'homme de revenir
désintéresser des pros pour nous c'est
très intéressant
il ya trente ans c'était brigitte lahaie
c'est à dire cette histoire de couple un
peu d'échangisme et c'est aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que c'est c'est beaucoup de
violence ils sont à 10 sur une fille la
tabasse et ses jeux pourquoi je pense
qu'il ya une raison
c'est parce que justement comme on vit
dans une société féminisé où les hommes
sont un pousse au fond imposer des
modèles féminins
ils se vengent par procuration il ya une
liane heureux en revanche une violence
latente fondation la ville en terme de
société où il ya plus d'éducation à la
maîtrise de soi c'est ça donc et on vit
dans une société de complexer alors ils
sont complexés alors il se rattrape en
appuyant sur le champignon dans la
voiture
alors tu es messi si vous avez quand
même une certaine image un peu plus
gratifiant de guerre celle de son
déficit d'éducation qu'est ce que c'est
c'est la mort du père c'est tout c'est
la mort de l'interdît et l'interdît qui
est symbolisé par le père et le père qui
suivait partout 30 ans d'évolution de
féminisme etc et de mort de la virilité
est demandée système patriarcal
non c'est la malle interdit tout 190
egos aux états unis qui sont qui sont à
qui on donne des produits chimiques moi
j'ai tout ce qui arrive de mal c'est la
faute aux hommes et je vais la faute aux
familles à défaut de partager il ya des
six
mais c'est vrai qu'on ne connaît pas on
n'est pas dans l'avenir n'est pas dans
la faute mais non mais pas dire que ce
que vous disiez sur vous en parlait
d'ailleurs pour les enfants de
l'immigration vous dites la mort du père
c'est à dire on a brisé la virilité du
père et maintenant il ya une
exacerbation que ça que la virilité des
enfants qu'est ce que vous pensez
christine car je laisse de cet argument
vous avez lu des livres mais bien sûr
c'est vrai que des enfants qui n'ont
plus un modèle de père valorisant encore
faut-il qu'ils aient un modèle de mourir
valorisant jeunes c'est à dire qu'un
père qui travaille à un père qu'ils
assument qui assume sa famille et c'est
ainsi c'est un père chômeur et sommiers
c'est sûr mais alors comment dans ce cas
là alors peut-être qu'il faut s'en
prendre de chômage peut-être s'en
prendre à une évolution et à moins
encore de travail de force encore une
fois on admire et le mineur on admirait
le l'ouvrier de force on admire - le
petit employé derrière son guichet ses
plans c'est moi dans la presse que
j'étais au départ l'évolution du
capitalisme
l'évolution du capitalisme de la
structure du capitalisme de l'est de
dons delà de la faute de la du travail
poussent à cette féminisation l'homme en
tant qu'employé bureau fait un travail
entre guillemets de femmes entre
guillemets de secrétaire et donc il est
humilié et donc il est féminisé c'est
cette distinction en permanence de
travail de femmes maintenant il ya des
tra et un travail qui est gratifiant qui
permet au corps et à l'esprit de se
développer un autre qui ne l'est pas on
va pas le classement féminin
mais d'apporter un certain nombre de
métiers peut-être qu'ils sont considérés
comme plus féminin ou plus masculin et
que même si l'on abandonne 1,7 en 2006
quand il se trompe quantifié par des
femmes et à linverse effectivement il ya
des métiers qui maintenant sont occupés
davantage par des femmes
quand ce sont des métiers qui se
dévalorise parce que les hommes vont
vers le zoo vont vers d'autres fonctions
où ils vont être mieux payés nous aurons
très juste d'avoir seymour qui dit oui
c'est une escroquerie la féminisation
l'homme n'abandonne jamais que ce qui
n'a plus de valeur
oui c'est ce que parce que c'est vrai je
le constate c'est tout à fait exact et
j'en conclus que si les hommes ont des
réseaux qui leur permette d'accéder à
certaines fonctions les femmes devraient
davantage à voir des réseaux et plus
solidaire et pas lésés sais pas si c'est
une règle de symbolique il ya une
symbolique entre l'argent et le phallus
c'est tout voilà que et la compétition
et l'esprit mais oui mais voilà le petit
bouton
de plus si vous franchissez le fallait
lorsqu'au terme est ravi de savoir que
vous en avez un
il faut pas le dire comme ça ça mais
finit par sabine mais c'est fragile
c'est tout à fait d'accord en fin de
parole de tendresse alors écoutez en
termes de en conclusion d'habitude je
fais une conclusion un peu synthétique
je vous proposais en termes de
conclusion eric zemmour voulez vous
faire un baisemain à christine je vais
très bien voilà pour ce débat merci moi
alors je rappelle le livre christine
clerc lettre à un petit garçon chez plon
un petit garçon que vous souhaitez
éduquer vous souhaitez faire échapper
eric zemmour le premier sexe chez denoël
qui fait un constat dur enfin un conseil
je crois dont on a débattu ce soir et ça
valait bien un baisemain n'est ce pas
[Musique]